Okay, hear me out.
If you have enormous amounts of money,
the right thing to do with it
is to help other people and the world.
Obviously.
But very rich people will likely spend
some money showing off,
and I can’t help feeling that
if that is going to happen,
then it might be nice if
things like this
came back into fashion.
In English, the word "water feature"
seems almost quaint.
It implies a small fountain
in a back yard
or a little stream
running down to a pond,
some little babbling-brook diversion
to break up a suburban garden.
But the German translation
for that is "wasserspiele":
literally, "water-games".
And if you were very rich German nobility
300 years ago,
water-games might include
a massive hillside park,
a seven-tonne, eleven-metre-high
statue of Hercules,
and a fountain that reaches
fifty metres high.
This is the Water Games of
Bergpark Wilhelmshöhe in Germany,
it's now a World Heritage Site.
The fountains and water features
here are powered by gravity,
and controlled on-demand by
hidden mechanisms in
underground pipelines,
some of which are centuries old.
IN GERMAN:
By the time you see this video,
the Wasserspiele will be open to
the public for the summer season.
But today, they are just testing.
A few lucky tourists were in the
right place at the right time,
but the team here didn’t announce
this was happening.
Except, they sort of did,
because first,
there was big release of water at the top
and the cascades that go half way down the hill.
And I really wasn’t expecting the noise.
[LOUD HONK]
[PITCH AND VOLUME CONTINUE RISING]
[horn fades] The rushing water brings
a lot of air with it,
and that’s forced through the trumpets
that the Herald statues hold.
The noise is immense, it’s a siren that
for 300 years has told anyone in the park
that the water games are about to begin.
The water goes through
a series of stations,
each a few minutes' walk apart,
and at each station
the water is released manually,
at a certain time,
one after the other.
After the cascades, there’s
the artificial waterfalls,
and then the bridge,
which leads to
the colossal aqueduct,
wind and spray all blowing around
from the force of the water.
And the crowds of people who’ll be
coming to watch this summer
will follow along,
walking the path,
waiting for the water
to be released
and for each show to begin.
So I assumed that
this was basically
one big river with some
engineering in the way.
But this was built in several parts,
by several different landowners,
so of course, it's more
complicated than that.
And it all ends here, at
the fifty-metre fountain.
Now, I’m not saying that
building things like this
should be a higher priority
for rich people than
feeding or housing the world,
or any other philanthropy.
Of course.
And okay, maybe not fountains,
maybe some other
big physical art stuff.
But I can’t help feeling that if someone
is going to spend huge amounts
on vanity projects to show off
their wealth to the world…
why not make them spectacular,
and fun, and built to last for centuries?